on the mound for the astros is
left-hander fraber valdez seven and
three a 3.22 era in 13 starts 78 in the
third inning 66 hits 36 walks 73
strikeouts league batting 225
against the 27 year old out of san
cristobal dominican republic
swing and a miss that ball was not
fouled by daza so he goes down on
strikes robert valdez picks up his first
strikeout
so here's trevor a little bit of
experience against valdez valdez threw a
very good ball game against the rockies
last year
trevor's over three the pitch home is
grounded past the led miss diaz in the
left field trevor story
now is it in 12 of his last 13 games
two on one out for krone then the pitch
is sliced into right field it'll drop
for a base hit connor joe comes around
third he scores story into third rbi
single for cj krone the rockies take a
one to nothing lead and the bases are
loaded for colorado with taylor motter
the hitter ground ball towards shore
carlos correa will have to play makes it
the first to get modern strand the basin
loaded antonio sensatella making his
19th start he's been far better at home
this year than on the road in fact on
the road he's on five with a 603
earned run average
at home a 404 so a two-run difference so
he's due for a for a good start away
from coors field
and brantley shoots one the other way
michael brantley continues with that
best batting average in the major
leagues
with a single to
[Applause]
start his afternoon since coming off the
il ledin is hitting over 300 302 with
three home runs
and 11 runs at him that ball hit hard to
the left center field that'll be down
for a hit brantley will score unless
miss diaz ties the game up with an rbi
single
astros get that run right back
1-1 ball game top of the third inning
jonathan dazza the right fielder will
lead things off
swing and a miss
one after a fastball
gaza has struck out twice robber has
four strikeouts here's trevor story he's
their best player the shortstop he
singled his last time up
as he goes down on the curb off robert
with back-to-back strikeouts getting
dazza and story five strikeouts now for
valdez
bring up a led miss diaz singled in the
left his first time up
there's one up the middle that'll be
down for a hit jordan had to hold up
he's being waved around garrett hampson
with a throw home your don will be safe
at home play
miss diaz has another rbi base and it's
two nothing astro
bomber valdez back out there he's
retired seven in a row right now
as he settled into this ball game he has
eight for his last 20.
ground ball towards the hole carlos
correa with that great arm on one hop to
taylor jones and against diaz
correa knew the catcher was running one
away in the fourth plant that right foot
show that good strong arm and a bit of
creativity getting that long hop over
there to make sure he gets that runner
modern playing his second game in the
big leagues this year as he just joined
the rockies yesterday here comes the 1-0
this one's popped up down the right
field line and foul territory long run
for jake myers and he'll make the catch
and foul territory up against the
netting he left
and pulled it down on a great play
in right field that's a nice play by
myers the degree of difficulty in that
corner you've got the netting you've got
the fans that was a great play by jake
myers nice to get that two out lightning
right here from chaz manning today for
the third time with runners in scoring
position
line drive coming in from right making
the play dazzle for the final out of the
inning
she wasn't allowed by from since the
first inning a couple of walks last
inning he worked around that
swing and a miss quick work of elias
diaz as valdez picks up strikeout number
seven one away go ahead run taylor
motters at first one out top of the six
astros with a two to one lead
garrett hampson to the plate flight out
to deep right his last time oh for two
and that's lifted in the left field
coming in alvarez reaches down makes the
knee high catch
two out that's a tough play right at
jordan
and he got a good jump coming straight
in the depth perception is very
misleading a lot of times fromer would
love to finish off this inning with a
big out here against the lefty sam
hilliard swing and a miss valdez
excited as he pumps his fist into his
glove with that strikeout he is through
six innings leading two to one i'll see
if martin maldonado can drive in the run
from third the rockies will bring their
infield in 2-2 another fast ball this is
lifted to right daza can throw it's not
that long a throw here comes myers here
comes the throw in time
out at the plate what a throw by dazza
see if the astros challenge it they are
going to meyers going to the outside of
the plate hand on it's pretty close
myers thinks he's safe there we go
that elusive run comes home for the
astros they've been hitting the ball
hard all day and they actually get a run
on a little pop fly
brantley has two hits today two for
three has that average up to 331. just
fall off the glove of shasine and no
chance michael brantley has his 53-hit
game of the year the most in the
american league here's correa he's one
for
three that's 16. there's a ball down the
line correa has extra bases brantley
heading to third he'll be waved around
the three-lay throw will not be made
brantley will score he goes in head
first just for fun
as carlos correa ends up with an rbi
double
here's the led miss diaz he's had a
great day at the plate he's been
swinging the bat as well as anybody
down the line in left oled miss diaz
hits one off the top of the wall carlos
correa will score on the diaz double
third rbi of the game for oled miss it
is five to one astros
have yourself a day of leadness
turn things over here in the ninth
inning to ryan presley in a 5-1 game
astros with a four-run lead one out
ninth inning for colorado
called third strike outside corner it
was close
honor joe doesn't like that call
he is out number two charlie blackman
will come on as a pinch hitter
swang and a miss ryan presley finishes
off the game with a strikeout
picking up a strikeout of the last two
hitters astros win it five to one and
sweep this two-game series of the
colorado rockies